dr. Kevin Spacey won two Academy Awards
for his performance in the usual
suspects and American Beauty he also
received a Golden Globe for the Netflix
series house of cards and a Tony Award
for it Lost in Yonkers here's a look at
some of Spacey's defining roles over the
past three decades we were just at a
seminar uh buddy this is my husband
we've met before but something tells me
you're going to remember me this time
if you pay attention there will be a
point the greatest trick the devil ever
pulled was convincing the world he
didn't exist yeah you know me I'm
keeping the streets safe boys for those
of us climbing to the top of the food
chain there can be no mercy there is but
one rule hunt or be hunted I got chills
and his latest role space is not a way
to wake up yes hot team of the hunted
hunted it's your delivery tube Kevin and
his latest role space he heads to the
court a real court the tennis court he
stars in the one-man play Clarence
Darrow it's based on the real-life story
the legendary defense attorney Gerald's
known for his infamous Scopes Monkey
Trial and his successful arguments
against the death penalty Spacey as you
know is also hosting the Tony Awards on
Sunday for the first time right here on
CBS so we're pleased to have him at the
table at Studio 57 like talking about me
like I wasn't here okay now you're here
Kevin Spacey let's start with the Darrow
role yeah because I think that the venue
was so interesting the Arthur Ashe big
stadium yeah it's never how did you
choose that well we did the show in
London when I first did it at the Old
Vic we reconfigured into a theatre in
the round you know I really wanted to
keep that way of doing it because I
there's a lot of audience participation
I go out to the audience I make them
read things I choose them as my juries
and there's something I think really
exciting about an audience watching an
audience watching a play yeah it's kind
of remarkable but what was it about
Clarence Darrow well Darryl himself is
just I think an extraordinary figure in
American life he was at first for people
who don't know a remarkable labor
attorney he fought for workers rights
for better conditions for hours in fact
he's the reason we have an eight-hour
day
although Charlie you don't work an
eight-hour day so no he doesn't that
doesn't make sense anymore and he also
became of course a huge civil rights
attorney he was never afraid to put his
head above the parapet I think he
managed to in all of his arguments use a
kind of homespun logic and humor to make
his points and he managed to convince
juries and judges that the issues and
causes he fought for were right and I
think that he managed to remove politics
and removes too
and just tell a person's story and when
you tell someone's personal story
prejudice does fall away you did I mean
he saved like a hundred people from 102
men he defended against the death
penalty and not a single one of them
right but when you bring him to life
it's just you and the words Kevin
because it's just you yeah no it is I
gotta say what makes it so much fun to
do this show is it is about the
relationship with me any audience um
it's not me just up there I'm out there
quite a lot and I but you're driving the
train definitely yeah so turning from
that to the Tonys the Tonys are a piece
of cake for you there you go I'm the
nerd host as you guys just add to this
nerds are in I'm looking forward to it
it's a first of all I'm a theater rat I
love the living theater I've learned
everything I know about my craft in the
theater so in the last two weeks I've
had a chance to go and see almost
everything and the season is incredible
I've been able to go backstage and see
all the cast and congratulate them on
their incredible work so I'm looking
forward a to having a good time
entertaining that audience and Radio
City Music Hall celebrating the season
yeah
so you took time off to go to London and
to run the avec you now left that what's
the plan for you now what are you doing
now
well I'm announcing today Canada I don't
know I'm in a sense oh you can come back
and be in and do a lot of movies you can
be back on theater are you gonna well I
would like a mansion I would like to
find a way to begin to continue to do
the things that I do particularly if
you're my foundation all the educational
stuff that we do and using the artists
and the tools of theater as an
educational tool to help kids learn
about self-esteem and and empowerment
and being able to collaborate I think
all of those things are incredibly
valuable and I would love to find a
place you know a home for that to exist
and for me to be able to start to do
more and more plays because I I love it
what is that you're about Frank under
what happens yeah see Kevin leo thank
you so much we all like you so much I
just live out for the women always
knowing would have said yeah any true I
know but I love house of cards we all
love house of cards I have to say what
do you like most about Frank Underwood
he's so complicated and so smart and so
so yeah yeah well I know you wonder why
so many completely different kinds of
things but I rather like so arrogant I
think I think yeah when he has to be
absolutely yeah I think that what's
really fun about him is is that for me I
continually learn things about with each
season we try to peel back a little bit
more of the onion and he's fun to play I
think that I'm incredibly lucky to have
great writers and I feel like co-stars
and great co-stars I mean you know Robin
Wright is yeah brilliant and Michael
Kelly and all of our cast so I love
doing it it's I didn't think actually it
could get better but every year it's
gotten better it's gotten more engaged
it's got more challenging it's got more
interesting playing off the headlines in
this country I don't think we really
feel the obligation to continue with the
real world I think we've tried to do is
to remain true to who we are the runway
that we're on and trying to tell our
story and I think although now it's very
interesting that a lot of things that we
might have done people thought oh well
that's crazy that could never happen in
Washington yes well maybe we're a little
closer to reality than people thought do
you like Frank Underwood I have to not
judge my characters yeah okay I have to
just play them you know for me did you
like Richard the third go ahead right up
until he killed the kids it's fine no
it's it's it's a funny thing I often
feel that if you if you allow yourself
to judge the person you're playing then
you wear that on your sleeve yeah it's
not my job to sit in that seat it's an
audience's job to decide how they feel
about why you ask that question yeah I
judge him but don't you find him likable
and yes yes that's right and then other
times I'm like oh yeah but the act but
you feel the same way about the CBS
bosses I love les Moonves yes oh is it
Ryan Kate oh I love them
man yes yeah how do you do contract up
for me no they've given banker already
oh no no no no it's a pleasure to have
you here looking forward to seeing with
the Tourneur it's going to Tony yeah
I'll be looking forward to seeing you my
daughter
yes we'll be laughing loudly and do not
away from the stage looking forward to
it yes Sunday no Kevin Kevin will
perform in clarence darrow for two
nights at June 15th and June 16th at New
York's Arthur Ashe Stadium I'll be next
week
that's next week and you can watch them
host the 71st annual Tony Awards is
Sunday night 8:00 7:00 central and CBS
will be right back